ja also ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich zu
diesem seminar zu dieser sitzung und es
geht um theorien der existenz des sehen
sie hier am titel
und wir haben uns verschiedene sachen
vorgenommen ich gebe ihnen jetzt mal so
im ganzen ganz kurzen einblick darin da
rein und was es heute gehen sollen
dieser zweiten sitzung die jetzt im
formalen und der einführung eben
gewidmet ist ich geh jetzt einfach ein
bisschen durch also was haben wir uns
heute alles vorgenommen
erst mal sage ich ein bisschen was zum
formalen ablauf des seminars da sie
wissen wie das abläuft ich habe ihnen
schon ein bisschen was vorhin gesagt ich
sage ihnen ein bisschen was zum
prüfungsleistungen auch wenn ich das
schon in der rundmail an sie geschrieben
hatte
die haben sie hoffentlich alle bekommen
wenn sie keine rundmail von mir bekommen
haben dann schreiben sie mir noch mal
eine e mail
aber ich glaube die hat jeder von ihnen
bekommen weil sie jetzt ja auch alle mit
in zoomen drin sind also ich sag mal was
information zur prüfungsleistung das ist
so der erste teil des vor geplänkels
dann sage ich noch was natürlich
inhaltliches zum mit seminar- und ich
stelle ihnen ganz kurz den seminarplan
vor den habe ich aber auch schon auf lsf
geladen und sohn auf die app und so und
dann wollen wir wenn man diese sache
geklärt haben wollen wir in die private
sitzung über drüber gehen dann stelle
ich die zeichen aufzeichnung ab und dann
haben wir so einen internen raum in dem
wir ganz frei und ungestört diskutieren
können und zwar eben über diesen text
von dem amerika und den ich ihnen auch
noch mit geschickt hatte der war
zugegebenermaßen nicht ganz leicht zu
verstehen aber man muss auch mal sich
mit so einer harten nuss ein bisschen
ausprobieren so dass zum programm der
heutigen sitzung und jetzt sag ich was
zum formalen ablaufen wie sie alles
schon gesehen haben und gehört haben ist
es ein format der virtuellen lehre und
das ist ein ganz besonderes anliegen
dazu ein paar dinge zu sagen
weil wenn sie solche wörter hören oder
begriffe wie virtuelle realität dann
verbinden sie damit eigentlich so was
wie computerspiele oder so was wie eine
simulation einer virtual reality dann
können sie so eine virtuelle brille
aufsetzen und dann den sinn seiner
illusionen in so einer simulation
gefangen was wir jetzt hier machen
virtuelle lehre hat nichts mit
simulationen zu tun also hier geht es
wirklich ganz klar ganz verbindlich um
eine ganz bestimmte form der lehre und
dann kann man jetzt noch unterscheiden
zwischen synchrone und asynchrone lehre
als synchrone lehre ist das was sie
jetzt gerade hier erleben also live
lehre echtzeit lehre und gibt es
synchrone lehre das wäre zb sowas wenn
ich ihn arbeitsauftrag gebe oder
leitfragen aufgebe was dann versetzt ist
also was nicht direkt jetzt in der
dozenten dozierenden relation geschieht
und ich glaube dass es die mischung
macht also ich glaube lehre braucht
immer ob sie jetzt virtuell oder analog
ist immer sowas synchrones so ein
ereignis moment als es heißt jetzt im
seminarraum oder jetzt hier über suchen
und es braucht so weiß was ihr
begleitend ist wo jeder teilnehmer jede
teilnehmerin selbst entscheiden kann wie
viel zeit nehme ich mir dafür schaue ich
mir das nochmal genauer anschaue ich mir
die aufzeichnung noch mal in ruhe an
oder sportlich ein bisschen vor
ich glaube wir brauchen diese beiden
momente um lehre erfolgreich beim
durchzuführen und dann gibt's noch ein
digitales begleit angebot da möchte ich
ihnen auch noch was dazu sagen habe ich
auch schon der rund mail geschrieben
dann sage ich noch wie gesagt was zu
prüfungsleistungen und das ist dann
praktisch diese formale geschichte also
wie gesagt virtuelle lehre ist nicht nur
bloße simulation sondern virtuelle lehre
eröffnet neue räume und möglichkeiten
und das ist mir ein besonderes anliegen
wenn sie es interessiert stelle ich
nachher auch wenn ich es auf youtube
gestellt habe unten in der beschreibung
im beschreibungstext ein aufsatz von mir
rein über die funktion von
philosophischen youtube kanälen könnte
sie interessieren stelle ich dann
nachher 1 zum download
ich bin der meinung dass sich virtuelle
und analoge lehre ergänzen
also ist die mischung macht es gibt kein
bevorzugtes format in meinen augen und
die korona krise wird uns jetzt eine
tolle möglichkeit mal die virtuelle
lehre auszuprobieren müssen wir alles
als eine chance nutzen genau es gibt
hier wie gesagt zur nachbereitung zum
essen grund gibt es von mir
zusammenfassung regelmäßig es gibt
gewisse es gibt arbeitsaufträge es gibt
leitfragen die können sie dann zu hause
in ruhe selbst machen und dann gibt es
eben hier diesen kanal philo cast und da
sehen sie schon drauf hier da es die
erste sitzung das erste video hat schon
231 klicks sie finden dabei auch andere
aufzeichnungen vom letzten semester aber
auch aufzeigen von diesem semester werde
ich da alles regelmäßig darauf stellen
abonnieren sie ihn gerne wir haben schon
über 2000 abonnenten und ich freue mich
über jeden neuen abonnenten
dann gibt es natürlich noch diese philo
cast app kostenlos für android und apple
und hier sehen sie auch schon im menü an
eintrag theorien der existenz ich hole
mal gerade auch meine app mal geradeaus
und also ich finde ich finde es ganz
übersichtlich so lädt sie jetzt und wenn
sie dann auf diesen reiter hier klicken
theorien der existenz also hier dann
finden sie hier die ganzen einträge
diesen roten logo die jetzt sicher auf
dieses seminar beziehen also zum
beispiel jetzt information zu hause
arbeiten können sie hier schon alles
praktisch nie für die westentasche und
seminar kann ich ihn empfehlen
und sie können aber auch hier schon die
ganze die seminare meine seminare der
letzten semester können sie ebenso
verfolgt also philosophie der
digitalität es könnte sie jetzt auch
interessieren
im zusammenhang mit virtuellen lehre
theorien der kausalität der begriff des
triebes und so weiter und der vorteil
ist diese ganzen texte die ich da drauf
stellt vor allem die zusammenfassung die
sind miteinander hypertext ul verknüpft
sie können dann von einem begriff zum
nächsten springen und so philosophin und
philosophen habe
auch immer ein paar biografische angaben
zb zu immanuel kant und finden sie im
bild von eben die geburts und
sterbedaten und sonstige
kurzinformationen dazu also laden sie
sich runter empfehle ich sehr ist ein
seminar für die westentasche oder für
die hosentasche oder für was auch immer
genau das zu dann jetzt noch kurz zu den
informations- und prüfungsleistungen
also sie können zwei arten von
prüfungsleistungen erbringen
entweder können sie also wenn sie jetzt
im bachelor studiengang studieren einem
haut oder nebenfach der hausarbeit
schreiben circa zehn bis zwölf zeiten
oder wenn sie im lehramt studieren dann
können sie in se bzw eine kurze
hausarbeit schreiben zirka sechs seiten
finden sie auch im sap system weitere
informationen dazu bisher also nach dem
neuesten stand nach dem aktuellen stand
ist der abgabetermin der mittwoch der
dreißigste september 2020 falls sich
keine änderung ergeben kann natürlich
immer durch die krise noch irgendwas
dazwischen kommen aber so sieht es
momentan aus und sie haben das merkblatt
für hausarbeiten gefunden
das habe ich ihm geschickt finden sie
auch auf der app schicken sie mir bietet
die hausarbeit oder diesen es bis zum 30
september 23 uhr 59
also kann auch natürlich dann ein und
kann auch ein bisschen später seien aber
wirklich so um also bitte bis
mitternacht möglichst mir per e mail
schicken an diese adresse
und sie bekommen dann von mir
wahrscheinlich noch in derselben nach
die bestätigung der e mail dass sie
beruhigt einschlafen können dass ich
erhalten habe dass er bei digitalen ging
immer so eine sache
ob es auch angekommen ist sie bekommen
die bestätigung von mir schreiben sie am
besten die betreffzeile der e mail
irgendwie hausarbeit theorien der
existenz oder so aber ich bin da sehr
gründlich kann ihnen versprechen genauso
viel zu dem haus arbeiten zum formalen
nehmen sie bitte auch rechtzeitig
kontakt mit mir
also wenn sie jetzt die helfer nach
hause weil ich werde natürlich auch
mögliche hause themen ihn rechtzeitig
schon zu schicken in einer liste wenn
sie dann so langsam die die haben
darüber könnte ich mir vorstellen so
nach hause bei zu schreiben dann nehmen
sie kontakt mit mir auf per e mail
wenn sie wollen können wir das auch
meine virtuellen sprechstunde dann
klären also irgendwie auf so oder so da
bin ich dann ganz offen aber übernehmen
sie die initiative
schreiben sie eine e-mail schicken sie
mir ein kurzes exposé so eine halbe
seite was sie interessiert das aber ist
noch ein bisschen hin aber nur das ist
jetzt schon wissen genau dass ist so
dass zu den hausarbeiten ich mache noch
ich weiß noch auf eine sache hin und
zwar wenn sie dann bei spiele brauchen
wie man haus arbeiten schreibt ich habe
ihn ja ein merkblatt geschickt wenn sie
aber ein video sehen wollen wo ich das
ein bisschen genauer erklären wie man
auch seine hausarbeit formatiert dann
schauen sie einfach in der beschreibung
oben im video dann bei youtube da habe
ich ein link rein gemacht wo sie eben so
ein screencast von mir sehen wie ich das
inhaltsverzeichnis formatieren und so
weiter und so fort also schauen sie
gerne einmal ein bisschen auf die
begleitenden angebote so soviel zum
formalen von hauser beiden jetzt gehen
wir über zudem leitfragen des seminars
theorien der existenz also eine frage
ist natürlich die was bedeutet es für
etwas zu existieren
sie sehen das ist eine sehr abstrakte
frage weil eigentlich setzt man sofern
man von über etwas spricht schon voraus
dass es existiert denn sonst könnten wir
irgendwie über das gar nicht sprechen
oder dass es irgendwie gibt sei sitz in
gedanken oder wie auch immer aber ohne
dass es irgendwie existiert könnte man
ja gar nicht über das sprechen über
dieses ding also das ist schon mal eine
typisch philosophische frage würde ich
jetzt mal
dann machen sich andere wissenschaften
nicht so viel gedanken drücken also die
biologie die fragt nicht was es bedeutet
zu existieren
die fragt was was ist zb ein corona
virus oder wie existiert ein corona
virus so was fragt sie aber so ganz
allgemein was überhaupt existenz an sich
ist das fragt die biologie nicht ist
auch gut so weil wenn sie sich nur mit
solchen fragen beschäftigen würde würde
so ein impfstoff für den crooner virus
noch ewig dauern also ist gut so dass
sie das der philosophie ball ist aber
eine schöne abstrakte sehr knifflige
frage dann meine lieblingsfrage was kann
alles existieren und was nicht das finde
ich ganz ganz spannend denken sie mal an
die figur hamlet oder an micky maus oder
eine sonstige filmfigur irgendwie gibt
sie es ja schon also im film also ist ja
nicht nur sie ist ja nicht da sie ist
schon irgendwie da aber wie genau
ja natürlich existiert eine filmfigur
nicht so wie eine reale person die wir
jetzt hier physikalisch auch sehen
können und damit den wir reden können
das ist klar aber irgendwie schon also
wie existieren fiktive gegenstände und
so weiter und so fort das ist eine frage
die wir hier im seminar erklären wollen
eine weitere frage die auch spannend ist
ist gibt es existenzen oder dinge die
mehr als andere existieren ja wir würden
ja gemeinhin sagen entweder etwas
existiert oder es existiert nicht ich
denke das würden die meisten von ihnen
sicherlich sagen aber in der
philosophischen debatte gibt es da
verschiedene ansichten über platon zum
beispiel auf den jetzt auch gleich noch
kurz eingehen werde
im überblick über das seminar platin
sagt ja es gibt dinge die existieren
wahrhaftig sie wissen was es ist das
sind ideen bei platon das sind die uhr
bilder die existieren wirklich und dann
also die existieren im höchsten maß im
höchsten grade und dann gibt es dinge
die existieren auch aber einem niederen
hat zb jetzt konkrete gegenstände bäume
bäume existieren durchaus aber nur
insofern als sie teilhaben wie platon
sagt an der idee des baumes und die idee
ist der begriff also dass die essenz die
definition und die idee das konzept des
baumes ist es eigentlich existierende
und der konkrete baum der ist nur in
einem geringeren grad existenz weil wir
ihnen ja auch nur existiere erkennen
können
insofern wird die idee des baumes
verstanden haben das ist natürlich
heutzutage recht contra intuitiv aber
platin hat gute gründe für seine anderen
nur soviel dazu das ist platin würde das
sagen ja eine weitere frage inwiefern
existieren fiktionale gegenständen
personen für das raumschiff enterprise
und pumuckl dass es betrifft auch so ein
bisschen die zweite frage hier die ich
schon aufgeworfen hatte auch eine
spannende frage welchen unter logischen
status haben virtuelle realität
das ist jetzt ganz konkret angesichts
der korona krise virtuelle lehre
virtuelle realitäten sind ja nicht bloße
simulationen sondern es sind wirklich ja
was sind das handlungen dinge aber wie
unterscheiden sich jetzt virtuelle
realitäten von physikalischen realitäten
ja das müssen wir auch noch klären und
das wollen wir am ende des seminars
machen das ist eine offene frage weil
das thema virtuelle realität erst seit
kurzem so philosophisch interessant
geworden ist weil sich die technischen
möglichkeiten gibt es da verbessert
haben genau noch eine frage ist
existieren lebendige wesen auf eine
fundamental andere weise als es andere
materielle gegenstände tun also man
könnte sagen leben zu leben ist eine
besondere art von existenz die das ding
noch mal auszeichnet über die bloß
materielle existenz also leben ist eine
besondere materielle existenz die das
ding noch einmal besonders macht das
finde ich auch spannend genau das sind
so die systematischen fragen also die
großen probleme und jetzt sage ich ihnen
noch was zum
tode und zu den zielen des seminars ich
mache meinen seminaren es immer so dass
sich historisch das heißt geschichtlich
als geschichte der philosophie und
systematischen fragen also die die
fragen die wir gerade aufgeworfen haben
die dass ich dir miteinander verbinde
ich glaube wir können nicht einfach nur
das systematische fragen sprechen wie
was bedeutet es zu existieren was ist
eine virtuelle realität ist nicht klar
wir müssen diese systematischen fragen
immer verbinden mit geschichte also mit
positionen in der geschichte der
philosophie mit bedeutenden philosophen
und philosophen
das ist um eine methode und das machen
wir auch in diesem seminar jetzt
weiterer punkt ist wir wollen den
existenz begriff von anderen verwandten
begriffen abgrenzen
gar nicht so einfach sie denken bestimmt
auch jetzt gleich ja es gibt einen ganz
ähnlichen begriff nämlich der begriff
des seins dass sein denn was ist denn
der unterschied zwischen existieren und
sein
das ist dasselbe ganz schwierig auch
wieder eine typisch philosophische frage
wo sich die biologie keine gedanken
darüber machen muss ist gut also ist
nicht macht aber wir als philosophin und
philosophen
wir wollen solche fragen eben ins
zentrum rücken kommen wir wollen das
nicht nur als der abstrakte begriff
spekulation machen sollen das ist eine
wirklich existenzielle frage was es
bedeutet zu existieren das betrifft uns
im innersten dann möchte ich anhand der
geschichte der philosophie also der
historischen debatte gewisse
entwicklungslinien und tendenzen
erkennbar werden lassen die die
behandlung des existenz begriffs
betreffen also ich möchte dass sie eine
gewisse orientierung haben in diesem
dschungel an existenz begriffen dass sie
ungefähr wissen es gibt diese positionen
es gibt verschiedene lager hinsichtlich
der frage was es bedeutet zu existieren
da gibt es dann immer anerkannt der
vertrieb diese position dann gibt es in
thomas von aquin der vertritt diese
position und dass sie angesichts dieser
verschiedenen positionen auch nicht nur
unterschiede erkennen können sondern
sich selbst auch positionieren
könnten sie sagen also ich bin der
meinung dass diese historische position
überzeugender ist als jene und zwar mit
diesen gründen
es gibt wie gesagt in der philosophie
immer pro und contra argumente für alle
mögliche theorien und sie sollen selbst
im laufe des seminars sich überlegen was
sie über am überzeugendsten halten was
die besten argumente in ihren augen für
bestimmte theorien sind da werden mit
wäre viel gewonnen wenn sie am ende sich
selbst da positionieren könnten sagen
können also diese theorie hier finde ich
besonders überzeugen und diese teile
überhaupt nicht und zwar aus diesen an
diesen gründen genau damit geht auch
einher da sie den existenz begriff
reflektiert und kritisch verwenden dass
sie also immer das buy-in so eine
alarmglocke geläutet wenn jetzt jemand
von existenz spricht der seo welchen
sinn von existenz main street mainz
trotz dieser hinsicht oder diese damit
haben sie auch viel gewonnen
genau das ist soll sind die ziele und
jetzt kommen wir zum seminarplan den ich
ihnen ja auch schon geschickt habe also
es gibt hier eben verschiedene
positionen und ich wir fangen wie
meistens eben mit platon alles kümmern
könnte auch noch mit parmenides beginnen
mit diesem vor sokratischen philosophen
aber wir beginnen mit platon in der
antiken philosophie und platon sagt es
gibt existenzen oder dinge die mehr als
andere existieren das hatte ich ja schon
angedeutet also zum beispiel ideen gibt
es und dann gibt es eben lose
gegenstände in der welt und ideen
existieren mehr als die gegenstände in
der welt tun
wir würden es gerade andersherum sehen
die meisten von ihnen
wir würden sagen die idee oder inbegriff
von etwas ist doch nur eine abstraktion
von dem konkreten dingen deswegen
existiert der begriff wenn er überhaupt
existiert viel weniger als das konkrete
ding was wir anfassen können also dass
da hat platin aus heutiger sicht ein
konto intuitive theorie aber er hat gute
gründe aber auch für diese theorie
das ist also in der nächsten sitzung am
plateau dann machen wir dann nach
aristoteles und da würde ich es ganz
kurz folgende beschreibung sagen wir
können in verschiedener hinsicht über
sein oder existenz reden
ich habe zuerst mal synonym gebraucht
aber wir reden jetzt bei aristoteles
über sein und da spielt die substanz
eine besondere rolle die substanz als
das ding das allem zugrunde liegt ein
eigenschaften
kurz gesagt dann thomas von der queen
habe ich jetzt noch mit hinzugenommen
den hatte ich im ursprünglichen der
letzten version des seminar plans nicht
aufgenommen
thomas von der queen war und zwar das
mittelalterlicher philosoph der sich
natürlich ganz stark auf aristoteles
bezieht
und er sagt folgendes essenz also das
wesen einer sache und seine existenz die
sind verschieden
wir müssen dazwischen unterscheiden
erstens also die essenz ihrer das wesen
und die wirkliche realität und wir
müssen auch noch klären was der
unterschied zwischen existenz und
realität ist wir neigen jetzt ja erstmal
dazu alles zu tun um zu verstehen seien
existenz realität ist doch alles selber
ist es wirklich müssen wir klären also
thomas von aquin zeit die zwei dinge
müssen wir unterscheiden
dann kommen also ein bisschen die frühe
neuzeit haben wir das mittelalter hinter
uns gelassen gehen wir zu leiten jetzt
über bleibt zwar eine rationalistische
philosoph und erlebte so im 17
jahrhundert und der sagt wir müssen
verschiedene modalitäten unterscheiden
modalitäten sind so was wie
notwendigkeit möglichkeit und
wirklichkeit als er betrachtet die
existenz aus einer modalen perspektive
damit haben wir auch wie gewohnt
natürlich gibt es alles schon bei
aristoteles diese unterscheidung aber
leibnitz ist da ein sehr prominenter
denker der das nochmal aufnimmt dann
gehen wir über zu david hume david hume
ist ein angelsächsischer philosoph als
ein schotte genau gesagt und der lebte
im achtzehnten jahrhundert zwar ein
sogenannter m pire ist
und der hat sich vor allem mit der frage
beschäftigt was wir wahrnehmen können
was wir erkennen können
und david hume denkt existenz von dingen
und ihre wahrnehmung also jungs spricht
von eindrücken von impressionen und für
konzeptionen
das bringt jung eine sehr enge
verbindung existenz und wahrnehmung
natürlich immer verbunden auch mit
erkenntnistheorie was können wir
erkennen das ist ein mp rist der sagt
wissen erlangen wir nur durch erfahrung
oder primär durch erfahrung dann gehen
wir über chronologisch zu immanuel kant
dem die auch in der heutigen sitzung mal
kennenlernen werden immer anerkannt
denkt existenz nicht so sehr von der
wahrnehmung her also nicht empirisch wie
es david hume macht sondern vom denken
oder urteilen her überlegt wie unser
verstand urteilt und daraus davon
ausgehend sagte etwas über die existenz
kanntest er ein rationalist wie leibniz
aber kann wie sie bestimmt schon gehört
haben ist ein philosoph eigene art
nämlich ein sogenannter transzendentale
philosoph was es damit auf sich hat wird
man auch noch genauer klären dann ja
dann geht es weiter zu einem philosoph
der heißt meinung der lebte im 19
jahrhundert und der hat sich vor allem
mit der frage nach existenz und
nichtexistenz befasst also in niefern
existiert hamlet es sind diese fragen
nach fiktiven existenzen nach fiktive
gegenstimmen
ganz spannend dann martin halliger den
haben sie auch schon alle gehört den
namen martin heidegger der befasst sich
jetzt mit dem was wir häufig auch in der
existenz verstehen wenn man zum beispiel
sagt infolge der korona krise ist meine
existenz bedroht das ist diese sinn von
existenz der tendenziell dann eher bei
eigene rolle spielt also existenz
wirklich im sinne von menschlicher
menschlichen dasein geht auch in diese
richtung existenzialisten muss heutiger
würde sich nicht als existenzialist
bezeichnen aber so diese
existenzialistische richtung an die sie
bestimmt auch gedacht hat
als sie den titel des seminars gelesen
hat eine theorie die existenz haben sie
bestimmt gleich ein existenzialismus
gedacht und auch der soll hier nicht zu
kurz kommt dafür haben wir eben martin
heidegger eingeplant da es seien also
menschliche existenz im unterschied zu
bloß gegenständliche existenz eines
losen steinen und äpfeln usw existieren
wir doch anders würden sie ja auch sagen
wie existieren auf eine andere weise als
das bloße steine oder computer oder
sonstige dinge tun ja dann haben wir
noch eine schöne gruppe von so genannten
analytischen philosophen also neuerer
art das sind gottlob frege das ist ein
philosoph des 1920 jahrhunderts
deutscher philosoph der so eine art
gründervater der sogenannten
analytischen philosophie ist analytische
philosophie ist eine philosophie die
nach naturwissenschaftlichen sehr
strengen kriterien philosophiert und
dazu gehört eben auch logik also
strenges philosophieren bedeutet immer
logische formalisiert barkeit
argumentative expedition objektive
erkenntnis nach dem ideal der
naturwissenschaften und da haben wir
hier vier philosophen in einer reihe wir
müssen schauen ob wir die wirklich alle
dann auch ausgiebig besprechen können
aber gottlob frege sicherlich der
wichtigste gottlob frege denkt existenz
und logik streng zusammen sie haben wenn
sie logik schon hatten haben sie
bestimmt schon mal sowas wie den
existenz quandt vorgesehen
ich kann dann auch mal vielleicht
nachher freigeben dieses gespiegelt de
ja dieses nach auf die andere seite auf
die andere achse gespiegelt de das ist
die existenz und so denken jetzt diese
denke über existenz nach dem logischen
sinne von es gibt einiges für das gilt
fx und soweit prädikate usw
klein ist ein amerikanischer philosoph
das weiter gedacht hat wie der von in
wegen der lebt noch der denkt eben
existenz auch sehr logisch und kidd
feiern das ist auch ein englischer also
stand als england auch ein gegenwärtiger
philosophie dazu bedeuten
das ist praktisch die analytische
philosophie die wir auch behandeln
wollen und als ausblick eben virtuelle
realität und fiktion vor allem virtuelle
realität
das ist so das was wir eben hier als
seminarplan uns vorgenommen haben
ja das ist eine ganze menge aber wir
wollen es versuchen und wir wollen
schauen ob wir vielleicht auf virtuelle
weise nicht doch noch mehr lernerfolg
erzielen können als auf analoge weise
das würde mich besonders freuen ich bin
da sehr optimistisch ich finde die
korona krise gibt uns trotz allen
schlimmen seiten auch neue perspektiven
die wir jetzt sinnvoll nutzen können
unter anderem eben auch in der
hochschullehre
so jetzt stoppt ich mal diese dem
seminarplan und geh weiter zum zu den
leitfragen der heutigen sitzung so wird
es also immer ablaufen das kann ich
ihnen jetzt bei der gelegenheit auch
noch sagen sie werden wie sie es auch
schon der letzten runde gesehen hatten
sie werden von mir
regelmäßige leitfragen per e mail
zugeschickt bekommen und diese
leitfragen sollen vorbereiten auf die
jeweils folgende sitzung und ich schicke
mir diesen leitfragen immer die
zusammenfassung der vorherigen sitzung
herum und eben den text auf dem sich
diese leitfragen beziehen
jetzt hatte ich heute formuliert
folgende leitfrage unter anderem welche
gründe sprechen für die auffassung dass
eine das existenz eine eigenschaft von
individuen ist welche gründe dagegen als
wenn sie jetzt von eigenschaften von dem
hören von individuen individuen sind
einzelne gegenstände dann würden sie
sagen der gut eine typische eigenschaft
von dingen ist grün zu sein ja alles ist
grün oder iks wiegt 300 gramm oder so
aber sie würden wahrscheinlich nicht
sagen dass eine eigenschaft eines
individuums eines bestimmten dings ist
zu existieren glaube ich jetzt nicht
aber wir diskutieren jetzt gleich
ich glaube die existenz ist als
eigenschaft für die meisten von uns viel
zu abstrakt um eine wirkliche konkrete
eigenschaft sein zu können weil das ding
muss ja schon existieren um überhaupt
eigenschaften haben zu können
also kann existenz eigentlich nicht auf
derselben ebene angesiedelt sein wie
jetzt grün und gelb und rot oder 300
gramm oder so was ist wenn dann so eine
eigenschaft zweiter stufe aber
eigentlich können wir gar nicht von dem
ding sprechen ohne es als existieren zu
setzen würden jetzt neuere philosophin
und philosophen sagen im anschluss an
kant andere wie zum beispiel thomas von
aquin würden das bestreiten die würden
sagen nein wir müssen da schon das
scheint ja dann dass es dann vor allem
das war auch dass wir in der heutigen
sitzung jetzt an der internen diskussion
eingehen wollen dann ist eben die frage
von interesse dann vertritt kann die
auffassung dass existenz eine
eigenschaft von dingen ist oder nicht so
viel kann ich schon sagen er wird die
drei auffassung dass existenz keine
eigenschaften ging ist er hat er
bestimmte gründe und wir lesen jetzt
gleichen text über den wir dann genauer
diskutieren werden den der sich ihnen
vor
und dann können wir in der internen
diskussion da weiter darüber sprechen
und dann das ist immer so eine
lieblingsfrage von mir das müssen wir
jetzt heute nicht ganz machen ich habe
dann nachher ein whiteboard und dann
können sie mir vorschläge machen wie man
das vielleicht formalisieren kann also
lässt sich dieses argument von kant dann
lässt sich das irgendwie rekonstruieren
als irgendwie formalisieren was er da in
diesem text sehr schwierig teilweise da
formuliert wie können wir das noch ein
bisschen klarer darstellen
na das sind so diese fragen ja jetzt
zeige ich ihnen noch mal kurz diesen mit
dem herrn hier das ist der immer
anerkannt wenn sie die lowcost app haben
dann werden sie auch in der
zusammenfassung der heutigen sitzung die
sie heute abend oder morgen bekommen die
auch auf diese app daneben zu sehen sein
wird ein hyper textuellen verlinkt
finden link finden zusammen
sohn und da werden sie dann auch noch
genauere informationen finden deswegen
erspare ich mir jetzt hier so ein
bisschen die biografischen informationen
finden sie alles wie gesagt auf der app
ich mache auch noch im beschreibungstext
danach holten die die links rein für
smartphones von android und von apple
zum download und das ist jetzt eben der
berühmte text und ich will jetzt mal
noch mal vorlesen
bevor wir dann in die geschlossene
diskussion über gehen das ist ein ganz
ganz bekannte text von immanuel kant aus
seiner kritik der reinen vernunft von
1781 bzw aus der b- auflage die ist von
1787 wenn mich nicht alles täuscht es
gibt da zwei auflagen mb bedeutet immer
die zweite auflage die später erschienen
und habe deutet die erste auflage von
1781 und ich lese jetzt mal den text
nochmal durch für sie vor und dann gehen
wir gleich so ein bisschen in diese
diskussion über aber können auch noch
über formale dinge bezüglich des
seminars sprechen nachdem ich jetzt eine
halbe stunde ihnen was präsentiert habe
als er sagt 100 wirkliche thaler
enthalten nicht das mindeste mehr als
100 mögliche thaler
denn da diese dem begriff jene aber den
gegenstand und dessen position an sich
selbst bedeuten so würde im falle dieser
mehr enthielte als jener mein begriff
nicht dem ganzen gegenstand ausdrücken
und also auch nicht der angemessene
begriff von ihm zeigt aber in meinem
vermögens zu stande ist mehr bei 100
wirklichen talern als bei den bloßen
begriffe desselben das heißt ihrer
möglichkeit denn der gegenstand ist bei
der wirklichkeit nicht bloß in meinem
begriff analytisch enthalten analytisch
bedeutet letztendlich als wie in der
logischen implikation als sie ihn kann
man daraus bröseln sondern kommt zu
meinem begriffe der eine bestimmung
eines zustandes ist synthetisch das
heißt gehalts erweitern hinzu
ohne dass durch dieses seien außerhalb
meine begriffe diese gedachten 100
thaler selbst im mindesten vermehrt
werden und jetzt kommt eben eine passage
die ich extra rot markiert hat weil die
so ein bisschen dass das kernargument
enthalten es sagt wenn ich also und das
ist eine schlussfolgerung achten sie
auch immer so ein bisschen auf
signalwerte wie also oder denn das zeigt
immer dass hier ein argument enthalten
ist wenn ich also ein dem durch welche
und wie viele prädikat ich will selbst
in der durchgängigen bestimmung denke so
kommt dadurch dass ich noch hin zu
setzen
dieses ding ist oder existiert nicht das
mindeste zudem dinge hinzu
denn sonst würde nicht eben dasselbe zu
einem mehr existieren als ich im
begriffe gedacht hatte das ist praktisch
die essenz von der thomas erwin spricht
und ich könnte nicht sagen dass gerade
der gegenstand meines begriffs existiere
denke ich mir auch sogar in einem dinge
alle realität außer einer so kommt
dadurch dass ich sage ein solches
mangelhaftes ding existieren die
fehlende realität nicht hinzu sondern es
ist existiert gerade mit demselben
mangel behaftet als ich es gedacht habe
sonst würde etwas anderes als ich dachte
existieren denke ich mir nun ein wesen
als die höchste realität ohne mangel so
bleibt noch immer die frage ob es
existiert oder nicht der hintergrund vor
dem kann dieses zitat jetzt schreibt ist
der geht der sogenannte und o logische
gottesbeweis das haben sie bestimmt
schon mal gehört das geht zurück auf
anselm von canterbury in
mittelalterlichen philosophie eben
gesagt hat wenn ich mir das allerhöchste
wesen was es überhaupt gibt denken kann
dann folgt daraus dass ich denken kann
auch dass es existiert weil wenn es
nicht existieren würde wäre es nicht das
höchst denkbare wesen also zum höchst
existieren dann wesen das ich mir denken
kann gehört eben auch dass es existieren
muss denn sonst wäre es nicht das höchst
mässig zu denken gewesen
das ist ja so genannte unter logische
gottesbeweis und den kritisiert hier
kann sehr sehr prominent all das ist im
rahmen einer größeren eines größeren
problemen kontextes dieses zitat habe es
sehr treffend weil es einfach
letztendlich sagt existenz und ex ist
als existenz und gedacht werden in
diesem sinne oder prädikats ion sind
nicht dasselbe also zu existieren es
nicht gleich bedeutend wie 300 gramm
schwer sein
da kommt nichts hinzu wenn ich zu einem
ding noch sage es existiert das ist
dasselbe ding weil es einfach sein ding
sein allgemein bezeichnet und nicht ein
konkretes prädikat